et bien bonsoir bienvenue sur des canal
spécial championnat du monde en direct
du riverside studio à londres avec
stéphane d'abord bien entendu
bonsoir stéphane bron soirée loi une
partie aujourd'hui exceptionnel déjà par
sa durée quatrième partie du match
nouveau record battu pratiquement six
heures et demie de jeu
une partie à fond une partie à fond
cramique a réussi encore une fois une
très très belle partie kasparov était
dans les cordes et on a vu un super
kasparov quand même qu'à poser un
maximum de problèmes dans une position
cochrane pouvait gagner
kasparov very good in escaping c'est
bien connu
kasparov s'échappe toujours on a même
quand on est gagnant on n'a pas gagné et
vladimir kramnik on a fait les frais de
la découverte aujourd'hui puisque il n'a
pas réussi à passer malgré une position
complètement gagnante une position
complètement gagnante et notamment
kramnik gagne un coup gagnant vers la
fin qui n'a pas vu ton g8 ont dans
l'occasion de revoir ce coup quand on
analysera un petit peu cette fin de
partie
c'est incroyable que j'aurai ce niveau
rate un coup qui a l'air entre
guillemets aussi évident à c'est
historique c'est historique dont j'ai
vite gagnant un coup et crame nick ne le
vois pas jouer un coup et ensuite c'est
nul directement immédiatement kasparov a
déroulé ensuite donc tout à fait une
cagade incroyable de vladimir kramnik
dans cette quatrième partie qui relance
quand même un petit peu le stand une
match parce que 3 1 ça aurait quand même
été catastrophique pour garry kasparov
là ça ne fait qu'un score de 2 et demi
un ennemi en faveur du challenger
quand même il va peut-être s'en mordre
les doigts notamment quand on va lui
dire qu'il a loupé ça et qui va se
rendre compte qu'effectivement il a raté
le gain alors qu'il n'aura peut-être pas
d'autre occasion maintenant surtout
lorsqu'il va se rendre compte parce que
pour l'instant les voyages a dit
exactement il n'a pas compris il a dit
bien sûr j'ai vu ça ne marchait pas et
oui pour tout un tas de mauvaises
raisons et exactement tout à fait et on
va voir ça tout a su tout de suite alors
je crois que d'abord on a quelques
images voilà de la fin du match ici
entre 40 et kramnik voile akrami que
sont les anneaux coût de la partie qui a
vu comment faire nul très facilement
krainik joue par inertie
mais là ça va très très vite il va
proposer nul après tour dh avec ses
derniers coups de la partie chronique va
l'amener son roi vers le centre et va
bien entendu proposé nul puisque c'était
une finale tour cavaliers contre tours
complètement nul voila mozilla et voilà
j'espère avoir accepté évidemment il n'y
a pas le choix et y signent la fin voilà
il discute après la partie ça s'appelle
eloi le l'analyse pour c'est important
parce que montaigne de joueurs
n'hésitent pas se donner leur sentiment
juste après la partie à noter que
pendant la conférence de presse il y
avait des remarques sur les coûts
possibles dix joueurs et kasparov a dit
oui non mais bien sûr mais en fait il
faut jouer en temps limité et il faut
jouer sur l'échiquier si on a un
ordinateur c'est plus facile on est tout
à fait non mais la question était en
l'occurrence complètement idiote
puisqu'un joueur n'avait pas vu penser
qu'il y avait une fourchette qui gagne
une tour alors qu'effectivement on
montrera à la fin il se passe absolument
rien d'autre qu'à sports ne répond pas
aux questions idiotes n'est pas question
qu'ils n'ont pas d'intérêt et préfère en
proprement envoyé chez la personne qui a
posé une question voilà cascarra of
toujours aussi agréable
alors on va voir tout de suite cette
partie d'aujourd'hui on va mettre notre
échiquier voilà une illustration alors
la première surprise de la journée dont
kramnik joue des 4es kasparov ne répond
pas par là grünfeld mais joue le coup le
week-end des 5 et 5 et rendant un gambit
dames après ces 4 2 kramix et 4 des
profs et 4 et la dépense et quatre
premières surprises voilà ça y est c'est
une deuxième surprise
quelle forme on ne rejoue pas la poutre
une fête c'est une première surprise
c'est une surprise il rend dans un grand
vide à m'accepter variantes qui n'a pas
là du tout l'habitude de jouer
effectivement c'est exceptionnel que
garry kasparov joue un gros bide à
m'accepter pourquoi parce que c'est une
ouverture qui n'offrent absolument
aucune perspective d' attaque une
ouverture extrêmement solide certes qui
a la réputation annulant ce réputation
de tralee zante mais c'est pas du tout
dans le style de garry kasparov
en revanche vladimir kramnik est très
content puisque ça lui convient très
bien
on va passer sur le coup d'ouverture
maintenant puisque ça c'était la
surprise de l'ouverture dont les joueurs
ont joué un début classique et on va
arriver à une position après tous les
coups qu'on va voir qui sont classiques
on va pas tout commenter parce que la
partie est très longue et on veut
montrer les moments les plus importants
de cette partie premiers moments
importants ici krainik joue le coup des
princes les temps qu on aurait pu
normalement sortir les pièces je crois
que c'est le coup qu'on joue
habituellement qu'avait laissé trois ici
le coût normal mécanique est très friand
de cette fameuse finale très connu cette
finale après dépensé 5 et eu énormément
de parties jouées krainik scorer des
très belles victoires
il a fait des très belles parties déjà
des parties mode
et ici il rajoute des procès cinq dames
1er tour prend d un fou prend ses cinq
premières positions intéressantes de
cette partie la position est symétrique
et aucune faiblesse dans aucun des camps
kramnik doit générer des coûts pour
trouver un avantage c'est pas facile
et là il va trouver un superbe passement
de pièces alors on va voir la suite
puisqu'il sort son cavalière d2
totalement anormal je dirais quand même
il a un plan chronique et un plan on va
voir que après qu'avec 17 photos deux
coups surprenant l'hiver la casse et 4
pour le cavalier éventuellement
d'antenne d'une allemande
on peut envisager de venir très vite sur
les caisses des six c'est possible garry
kasparov joue b6 et la cram ligue fait
un contre-pied pas ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un contre-pied puisqu'il va avec
le cavalier sur la case d3 il attaque le
fou fou qui va être obligé de deux
reculs et on va avancer peut-être lois
tout ça pour arriver à la position il
est des catalans à temps parce que ça
quand même c'est quand même pas un coup
à wemmel on va on va il vise la castille
ci vise la casse et 6 il met pas le
cavalier qu'on attend évidemment on
pense ici il ambitionne le couffo f3
alors en fait pas du tout sûr fourbe et
cette chronique a vu plus loin il a vu
un plan positionnelle pour le pion très
intéressant et ils ne jouent ils jouent
f2 f3 très très fort voilà il veut jouer
l'autre camp sur la case de 4 et ainsi
lutter contre le foot bessette
de toute façon kasparov n'a rien à faire
donc les deux prochains coups c'est
petit roquet a eu quatre voilà petit
rock et 4 et voilà ça y est tout de
suite kasparov buts contre le pion eu
quatre avec son fou qui est enfermé
c'est un roc
le fou est enfermé le chat 6 commence
lui aussi ne peut rien faire contre ce
pion il est donc complètement dominé si
on voit les cases où il peut aller
maintenant il ne peut plus aller nulle
part
donc ici cramique grâce à son plan de
pions arrivent à limiter l'action des
pièces de garry kasparov qui lui joue
tours fc vite joue des coûts très
normaux tout à fait cramer xv e 3 et là
je pense qu'on peut s'arrêter un instant
pour commenter la position de ces deux
fous qui ne vont pas bouger pendant très
longtemps
exactement c'est très important c'est de
fou en deuil à la fois sur la gauche
parce qu'il tape tous les deux sur les
pions à 6 et b6 et aussi sur la droite
éventuellement y contrôler aussi des
diagonales des diagonales qui pourraient
être intéressants notamment parce que
kramnik a la possibilité de prendre de
l'espace à droite donc pour l'instant
très bien joué par vladimir kramnik
très bonnes dispositions de pièces garry
kasparov lui n'a pas grand chose à faire
c'est de fous sont moins bien placé il
ne sait pas trop comment faire tout
simplement une girouette 8 et maintenant
qu'elle va l'aider de encore entré au
likoud chronique qui décidément ne les
quitte pas à manoeuvrer sévère voit la
menace probablement cavaliers en c4
menace clairement de venir ici en c4
avec une très belle position de
cavaliers et ce cavalier va faire
pression encore sur b6 et si les noirs
jouent le pion pour l'attaqué il va
aller sur poster sur la case à 5 ce
qu'amélie oui tout à fait et en cas de
b5 immédiatement ce serait une faute
professionnelle grave puisque chronique
pourrait commencer à ouvrir les lignes
avec justement c'est de [ __ ] est bien
placé garry kasparov du cabillaud 5 très
logique
ils empêchent la ville c4 et la cram etc
alors à jouer un enchaînement d'en faire
du local et 4 baies 3 attaque
immédiatement le plan b 6 le fou ou
trois attaques b6 donc la classe par an
fait quasiment obligé de jouer le coup
tours c6 qui protège le plan b si c'est
permet éventuellement de doubler les
tours sur la colonne gramm leach autour
ac 1 et doit sa victoire à ses huit
tours prend de vous prendre tout reprend
et là on sentait que cramique douter
quand même il avait il faisait une mine
un peu déconfite un petit peu genre
bomba kasparov de faire nul il va y
arriver je ne peux plus rien faire mais
non kramnik on avait peur que cramique
fasse nul rapidement tout à fait mais
non kramnik n'est pas ici pour rigoler
il est ici pour jouer tout est parti à
fond il a démontré y prendre toute les
chances
et même quand la position illégale il ne
se contente pas de là nul
il a vraiment changé peut-être son style
hélas pas peur de kasparov en tout cas
hélas il y va du coup j'ai lâché 4 qui
est très offensif risqué puisqu'il va
ses pions maintenant sont plus exposés
il prend de l'espace de notre côté sur
le roi et il va on va voir qui va créer
des contre chant lyrique espoirs réagit
très logiquement pas h 7 h six
chroniques continuent h4 est maintenant
un coup incroyable de garry kasparov qui
joue 21e qufu s'est vite et qui déclare
à la conférence de presse c'était le
seul coup quand même surprenant
oui c'est surprenant donc avis qui
n'engage que le champion du monde garry
kasparov puisque évidemment personne sur
terre ne comprend cette déclaration choc
fou s'est vite c'est le seul coup
honnêtement ça a plutôt tendance à fait
rire enfin rappelons quand même que si
les noirs peuvent jouer des scènes dans
cette arme d'un certaine variante
maintenant cavalier à 5
de suite d'un tapis le fou oui c'est une
idée mais enfin ça a pas l'air bref
ouais bref on s'est vite quand même
c'est quand même pas un très joli coup
ramené que lui envoient g5 et la
chronique envoie la purée comme on dit
avec g5y commencent à mettre la pression
sur les noirs et orange dès 5h prendre
les singles cavaliers fils est obligé de
bouger
il vient 17 et la chronique continue la
vence de ses pions et donc resserre la
position des noirs il prend un avantage
espace certains tout à fait ici les
québec kasparov sont chassés les uns
après les autres ils occupaient des
positions intéressantes en abscisses et
aux 5
maintenant ils sont obligés de quitter
leur poste pour passer en 17 est aussi
ce qui est beaucoup moins agréable
d'autant plus que les pièces de kasparov
sont un peu embouteillée on voit le
fossé vite keller mal placé le fou aux 7
qui n'a pas trop de perspectives et
évidemment ce cavalier g6 dont l'avenir
semble très compromis mais là faut jouer
très précis évidemment parce que la
moindre erreur
kasparov peut déplier ces pièces est
l'année de profiter de l'avancé des
pions blancs qui peuvent s'avérer faible
krasniqi a très très bien joué ici je
crois vraiment un très bon coup on
attend des cavaliers des cadres on ne
savait pas trop comment cra munich
pourrait jouer puisque effectivement dès
qu'ils avancent un des deux options soit
0,4 soit 9,4 il ya des faiblesses qui
apparaissent et les footeux kasparov se
retrouverait à ce moment là bien placé
dans une chronique en fait ne fait rien
dans cette position 12 25 câbles et f3
dans la cabine f3 provoque kasparov et
là que ce parent offre quatre ans ne
sait plus quoi faire
ne sait plus quoi faire elle a
semble-t-il fait une faute il y fait la
cades il fait une fois depuis ce qu'ils
jouent le coup qui a l'air bon puisqu'il
a l'air d'instaurer une contre attaque
tour ces deux attaques le fou c'est de
lefaux 2 et le pion b2 évidemment il a
vu ce qu'il allait suivre il n'a
peut-être pas tout calculé patron
kramnik rentrer dans les complications
tout de suite avec le coup suivant fou
prend à six coups surprenant le fou
s'est vite s'il prend le fou évidemment
le cavalier 17 étant prises et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que va jouer
kasparov
de toute façon kasparov n'a pas le choix
ici les deux joueurs donc si on revient
à la position précédente qui est celle
là kasparov envoie la tour en c2 il a
évidemment vu sept petites combinaisons
tactiques fou prend à six autres
possibilités pour crown et quand il faut
le mentionner il pouvait jouer tour d2
avec une position égal oui pouvez
changer ensemble de la position reste
sur l annuler évidemment chronique à
calculer très précisément fou prend 1,6
mais par quoi on pouvait se demander la
question est-ce que cramique avec av
les épaules pour jouer pour le gain est
vraiment pourri gagnant ce match et ça
ça fait plaisir
on sait que kasparov ne va pas avoir la
vie facile quoi qu'il arrive
oui de toute façon c'est plus dur de
jouer g2j 4 comme il l'a joué alors que
la position était à peu près équilibré
que fou prend 1,6 puisque fo prend 1,6
avec un calcul précis évidemment qui a
été effectué par krainik eh bien on voit
que les blancs sont nettement mieux
oui tout à fait donc on prend 1,6 il
faut reprendre et après tout quand
cavaliers les blancs pour l'instant
cette option de plus dont kasparov doit
récupérer un point après tour promet 2
hélas le droit tout simplement tour à
cette attaque le fou et une fois que le
four à bouger protégera le pion à deux
menaces tout va vite stéphane que tu as
oublié de mentionner sa menace aussi
voilà évidemment très important puisque
si noir prennent le pion à deux le coup
tu auras huit échecs récupère le fawcett
qui va être obligé de se sacrifier tout
à fait d'ailleurs on peut faire une
simulation de cette variante surtout
reprend pion à 2 et bien tout rabbit
convoi qui a plus de coup il faut jouer
fou des mythes ça donc ça perd donc une
pièce c'est le seul coullery la partie
donc ici bon bien entendu kasparov la
vue et zhu foulée cinq coups très normal
sur quoi cramique envoie le bois avec le
coup f5 et pro chasse pour la pente
qu'elle est il profite de la mauvaise
position de calais g6 pour le chasser
après pions préemption prend on voit que
la seule case de ce cavalier c'est la
casa suite et qui n'est donc pas la case
la plus agréable
c'est une horreur ça serait chabalier
sortira plus jamais ses caprices twh
soit les noirs jouent et si c'est ce que
l'on joue chez cissé c'est fini ce camp
il y sort plus soit il joue et si c'est
dans ce cas l'air ou g6 voila voila
c'est de toute façon le cas il ne
sortira plus ici kasparov trouvent des
moyens ils jouent tours 2 un coup qu'on
appelle intermédiaire puisque il attaque
le fou donc si on prend le cavalier
qu'elles peuvent apprendre le fou et si
le faux bouge le cavalier trouvera un
poste intéressant soit 11,5 soit en f4
donc espoir soit un taux intermédiaire
et on n'attaque personne n'a compris
pourquoi kramnik n'a pas pris en b 6 et
oui comme il pouvait prendre un v6 mais
il a trouvé un coup qui a l'air aussi
fort en fait finalement ce n'est plus si
ce n'est plus peut-être cavalier est
délicate et des quatre avec l'idée que
si les noirs prennent le fouet trois
billes perdre la partie parce qu'on
prend les siens lui
du coup on prend le fauve et 5 et aux
menaces à la fois pur on prend cavalli
g6 et tours à huit échecs qui récupère
le fou ce que les noirs ont obligé de le
donner pour éviter le mat
voilà donc ici pas de choix garry
kasparov ne peut pas prendre ce fou 1 3
il doit revenir avec toro et la ville a
dit mir crown et chauds ou froids f2
attaque la tour exactement tour eiffe un
échec et forcé puisque pour l'instant
kramnik en fait
kasparov avait trois pièces en prise à
ce moment là il ya trois pièces emprise
pour kasparov rizzuto a fait un échec 3g
deux cavaliers h4 kasparov arrive en
fait à sortir toutes ces pièces avec
échec au roi je crois encore de pièces
attaquer tout rachat un échec c'est
mettant toutes les pièces à la défense
la chronique actifs sont rois toujours
moi j'étais un rocher 4 où il fallait
évidemment jamais venir sur une de ces
deux cas noir durant la série d'échecs
puisque sarr permis aux fossettes de
revenir en d6 et ça enlève mais avec du
temps coup ça enlève la menace tours à
huit échecs
il est toujours dans l'air roy g4 donc
fou évite la kasparov
apparemment on veut retrouver une
position solide mais les crânes y plus
loin puisque le coup suivant fut f2 le
problème de kasparov c'est ce cavalier
h4 qui malgré ses neuf ans que rien
voilà ou deux c'est superbe
parce que là on a l'impression d'un
manque chronique est dans la boîte et
notamment actuellement là il semblerait
que d'après les analyses le coup kalyev
trois ans ferme cavalli g2 puisque ce
cavalier maintenant est complètement
bloqué
le cavalier les quatre la manière ni là
ni là ni là ni sur la case un nid sur la
case gien tout est contrôlé par fou
cavalier est roi et donc ce cavalier est
perdu on pouvait encore s'en sortir il y
avait des coups comme fou des six il y
avait des possibilités pour les noirs
mais la position était très très
désagréable à la place de ce coup
cavalière trois qui étaient très forts
cramique se fourvoie barcelone mauvaise
wenzhou tour habite
visiblement il n'a pas vu la ressource
de kasparov visiblement là ils ratent
l'occasion et la casse pour revenir dans
la partie et surjoue tempo tour eiffe un
très bon coup oui très à noter quand
même que les joueurs sont en inox
c'est important parce que là maintenant
la menace évidemment et tout reprend
fouet après le coup roy f3 ou roger 3
kasparov aurait pu mettre son cavalier
sur la case f4 recentrant sa pièce
puisque maintenant ce cavalier est en
prise par le roi mais ce roi prend
cavaliers évidemment on prend le fou et
on va voir que ici kasparov ne joue pas
qu'à liège 4 et l'incroyable se produit
il fait une gaffe cavaliers h4 c'est une
gare 38e
coup c'est une énorme gaffe peut-être la
plus grosse qu'on ait vu dans un
championnat du monde
en tout cas pour l'instant dans cette
partie oui parce que kasparov n'a pas vu
pour voir 3 e 2 la tour doit bouger en
h1 oui parce qu'il faut garder le
contrôle sur le cavalier kasper n'a pas
vu le coup suivant notre ami cavaliers
b5 qu'elle n'a l'air de rien mais menace
cavaliers sur la cades c7 et on voit
qu'il ya aucune possibilité pour les
noirs d'empêcher ce cavalier de venir
prendre le fou et 8 puisque ce fou et
clouer et que les juan les noirs pardon
ne peuvent pas ceux des clous et ni
empêché le cavalier de venir sur cette
case incroyable donc faute énorme de
kasparov
alors quand même 4 lecavalier si la
cassure fait jouer le caviar f4 le
khalife 4 aurait pu revenir sur la case
des 5
oui oui tout à fait et donc contrôler la
casser cette belle euros serait pas venu
à eux deux s'étaient tous différents et
en l'occurrence avait pas cette
combinaison quel sport tu n'as pas vu
qu'un médecin qui l'a dit la conférence
de presse ici à menacer qu'elle et ses 7
qui est imparable donc c'est cuit
kasparov va perdre une pièce tout le
monde attendait l'abandon et enfin wayne
on va voir kasparov et justement
kasparov l'ajout n'a pas peur il fait
quand même fou prend gsm qui récupère
déjà un pion et l'afrique avait laissé
cette recette et cavale et prend 1,8 il
a peur d'une pièce mais on va voir qui
va trouver des ressources fabuleuses
dans cette position qu'il commence par
prendre le pion aux 5 fu prend b6 roi
17la après à 4 tout le monde pensait que
c'était complètement finie on voyait le
pion à en train d'avancer furieusement
très vite en aide à les joindre
quasiment adam
on ne voyait pas comment l'arrêter
kasparov apparemment a commencé à
maintenant à trouver les coups les plus
précis en tout cas ce qui pose le plus
de problèmes effectivement puisque
kasparov joue le coutour h3 qui coupe le
roi blanc 3 peut-être kramnik aurait dû
monter son roi au lieu de jouer à quatre
en d3 réunion oui c'est gagner aussi
mais peut-être un des leurs est
peut-être plus facilement trouver les
coûts s'il avait d'abord joué au roi des
trois pour essayer de
ne pas avoir son roi coupé et on va voir
que ça va poser un gros problème parce
que kasparov va menacer des choses
qu'elle a laissé cinq échecs
pour moi c'est nice et à 5 et là
effectivement kasparov réfléchi 50
minutes ou 40 40 45 50 je ne sais plus
réfléchie une éternité et ne trouve pas
se tape la tête fait ses mimiques
habituelles
on a l'impression que garry kasparov a
abandonné d'un moment à l'autre
puisqu'ils ne trouve pas il est là il
est décomposé simplement dans cette
position et il trouve une manoeuvre
proprement incroyable totalement
inattendue tout à fait tout le monde
s'attendait à ce qu'ils cherchent des
échecs perpétuelle puisqu'on voit qu'ils
contrôlent beaucoup de cases autour du
roi blanc notamment qu'avec des cas
d'échec par exemple s'est rendu compte
que sur un jeu précis des blancs n'y a
pas d'échec perpétuel et c'est sûrement
une mauvaise piste
oui tout à fait et kasparov y trouve
autre chose à retenir tour trois échecs
roi des huns 3d et après tours 7
on voit que kasparov menace un cavalier
de trois échecs dévastateur parce que ce
cavalier qui vient à eux trois forces
auraient le roi ici à jouer soit sur les
cases noires soient devant la tour ce
qui permettrait aux cavaliers de
rebondir sur la caisse des cinq avec un
échec à la découverte
oui soit du foso de la tour soit du foso
de la tour il faut pas rester cheikh est
après ce cas il peut prendre le pouls b6
et récupérer le pion ce qui donne deux
des grandes chances de nul au noir voire
même quasiment là nul alors chronique
jeu très précis ici le tour s'est vite
échec roi b5 et la superbe coup non
prévus totalement imprévue totalement
imprévue ont lâché avait lieu quatre
cavaliers 4 qui coupe la tour justement
de l'échec
nous tenons sur cavaliers 3 il ya plus
cette possibilité car il faut prendre
trop à stephen williams 29 ans qui
revient à contrôler les galères de
gagner une pièce d'ailleurs men octobre
a gagné son fait mon bref et donc alors
le ici
kasparov est obligé de prendre la tour
puisque en fait on menace beaucoup de
choses ont masqué et des six échecs on
menace pour ces cinq échecs et menace
qui est profonde et cinq ans menace
surtout tour c'est la ligne que celle
qui lie à des menaces en classant les
spurs doivent prendre aux cavaliers et
après jour c'est sur ces chèques échec 3
à 6 grammes il récupère une caisse il a
simplifié qu'elle laissait cet échec
d'abord que les intermédiaires braver
cette tour preuve cinq là tout le monde
se dit c'est fini ça dit et kasparov et
non et non il trouve encore et trouve
encore un coup en défense totalement
hallucinante du champion 3 poule 3 très
bien vu il a compris que le fou mais si
c'est très important parce qu'il
contrôle des cases qui paie
mettre au pilon blanc d'avancé et que
donc il essaie dé changer cette pièce
parce qu'il se rend compte que la finale
tour cavaliers et pion à na ne doit pas
gagner si facilement
oui tout à fait d'autant plus qu'on voit
le fou des six qui a un rôle extrêmement
important y défend le calice et cette
idée fend le coeur a5
bon bref c'est une pièce clé il faut les
changer faut prendre trois tours premier
3 pour preuve cette là on se dit que
cramique s'est fourvoyé puis ce dernier
encore on ne sait pas trop si la
variante si la finale est gagnante ou
pas en fait on se pose la question est
là un tour c'est la torah 5 et après à
6,6 échec wabatinga b6 kramnik joue le
coup tout au long du set et là on
al'impression pourquoi on se pose la
première question programming ne joue
pas le coup enfin kasparov ne joue pas
le coutour c5 keller d'annuler tout de
suite à leur tour ces cinq effectivement
coup intéressant ça attaque le cavalier
ceux qui avaient les défend le pion on
se dit qu'il y avait des bouges le roi
vient prendre le pion et on a
l'impression qu'on peut prendre le
cavalier sans risque de faire le col et
blanc face dame est en fait il ya une
pointe stéphane il y avait le cou à 6
voilà le cou à cette qui effectivement
gagnent la partie puisque le rock
rampillon est obligatoire et la cavalier
e 6 échecs de la tour et la tour c 5 et
perdu donc gain des blancs donc il
fallait vite évidemment ces deux
variantes donc on comprend maintenant
pourquoi pourquoi kasparov ne l'a pas
joué
kasparov ne l'a pas joué il a joué tour
à 5 et là on pensait que c'était
probable en perdant moi en tout cas
j'avais cette impression roi des deux
bien jouer travnik tu auras un roi ces
deux on avait le droit vers la tour et
oui parce qu'il faut éviter un il faut
pas jouer gros ces trois causes autour
c'est un échec qui prend le cavalier c7
et la tourache un roi b2 l'a fait lors
la faute incroyable alors avait deux
voies la rejoindre ausy tour alors
kasparov et tourache 1 lens 10 qui va en
empirant agit bien joué on nie en fait
qui va faire des échecs on se dit on
c'est en fait on est à grand chose à ce
moment là parce que ça c'est votre avis
points exactement on dit kasparov va
sans doute essayer de faire des échecs
comme ça des fois on peut se dire qu'il
a envie de revenir en hbp 8 mais on ne
sait pas trop ce que veut faire kasparov
mais en tout cas en regardant bien cette
position on s'aperçoit très vite qu'il y
ait un gain évident pour les blancs et
oui un gagne pour les blancs tout de
suite c'est donc ce tour ce couteau
rachel hurd est une faute
est-ce que kasparov pouvait pas tenir la
position autrement sûrement pas sûr pas
sûr mais avant vous aussi possible en
tout
g ikram le couver gagné rate le coup
gagnant c'est surtout rejet 8 surprenant
superbe tour g8 qui menacent tourbe et 8
échecs et le roi ne peut pas les en a
sept sous peine d'être matt andré cette
menace tourbe éviter cette chasse
endroit l'idée bien entendu c'est que le
pion à à une voie royale par exemple ce
roi prend ses 7 directement à cette a7
et a8 dame était est imparable
on a joué tour à tour à 1 c'est tout à
fait imparable et après le drame il faut
donner à tous et donc c'est gagner ici
autre possibilité mentionnée par
chronique qui pensaient que c'était la
défense pour les normes le coutour h7
est oui et en fait ce n'est pas une
défense puisqu'ils s'y lie à tour de vis
déjà tombé huit échecs et si le roi
avant à 7
évidemment il est mat ensuite on va
l'indiqué on voit cette tourbe et cet
échec et mat échec et mat et l'amicale
le roi prend le cavalier c7 seul coup
pour empêcher à 7 sur le coup pour
empêcher à 7
effectivement c'est ça même temps en
peluche même pas à cette tourbe et 700
me cherche même pas à certains poèmes
jouer assez peu joué au 17 gagne à tous
nos besoins de tours à 7 gagne la partie
à séparer la partie aussi de toute façon
il est cuit et oui donc ici
l'incroyable s'est produit cram nick n'a
pas joué tour g8 dans cette position il
a réfléchi longtemps
il a joué il a joué il a joué l'horrible
roye b 2 laissant passer sa chance dans
cette partie oui parce qu'après
maintenant alors maintenant kasparov
était impitoyable je crois c'est tout
rage suite sefyu rage suit on sait que
la partie va être nul parce que là la
menace ses tours ses huit menace
imparable est impossible pour ces huit
ses vannes vendredi à ssl nom ainsi que
les bouchons procure à 6 on va vous
défiler les coûts de la partie puisque
ça encore jouer un petit peu cram dit
qu'ils étaient énervés robe et trois
tours s'est vite à cette une tentative
rapport à cette ya pas de bluff robes et
4 aura b6 qui avaient des cinq échecs
un piège effectivement si le roi noir
vient en c6 il ya la fameuse fourchette
il y à la fourchette en recettes
car l échec et on prend l'atome
évidemment en classe par an à 6 ils
joueront à 6 tours j'ai six échecs 3b
7,3 b5 mais là c'est la finale tour
cavaliers contre tours et c'est nul et
c'est complètement nul kasparov a joué
tout instantanément torcéen facile donc
j'ai deux grammes dit que sans
conviction assez vite le roi noir s'en
va tous rejettent cette 3d vite on peut
pas gagner cette finale
on ne peut pas gagner cette finale en
tout cas pas celle là et c'est ici cette
position qui a provoqué la fameuse
question de la personne du public qui a
dit je ne comprends pas kasparov vous
n'importe quoi vous n'avez pas vu touche
et vite c'est quand même incroyable on
est dans un chat perdu monde tour j'ai
misé sur 7 il ya la fourchette avec les
dessins crime et malheureusement il ya
encore le coup droit au fait qu'est ce
qu'on refuse de répondre bien
aujourd'hui puisque dans cette position
il ya évidemment roi et 7
si les blancs près de la tour et bien
les noirs prennent l'atome et là c'est
clairement nul on peut pas mater avec un
cavalier valable tout à fait donc la
position se termine à 1 6 tours fc est
qui est des cinq 3,17 là le roi noir est
totalement sécurisé ou essayant voit que
craint ni n'a pas réussi à progresser de
toute façon et que les noirs sont
beaucoup mieux qu'au départ et la
kasparov et des échecs depuis derrière 5
propose nul évidemment il ya tour échec
c'est très facile pour lire et kasparov
de faire nul dans cette position donc la
chronique rate un gain ça aurait été une
grosse surprise que crâne england de
points ça aurait été superbe ça aurait
été superbe
parce que la chronique a vraiment dominé
kasparov encore une fois la
problématique maintenant de ce match
mais c'est clairement kasparov qui
n'arrive pas depuis le début à
surprendre kramnik ou en tout cas quand
il arrive à prendre un peu l'initiative
comme c'était le cas dans la troisième
partie ils n'arrivent pas à concrétiser
kramnik lui a réussi à concrétiser dans
la deuxième il aurait dû réussir encore
gagné cette partie ci très longue et
pour lequel a mis beaucoup d'énergie
pour celles à gagner alors peut-être un
tournant du match
un tournant de ce début de match reste à
savoir ce que va faire kasparov demain
en tout cas c'est sûr que demain ça va
encore être une partie où les deux
joueurs vont s'employer à fond parce que
tout démontre que les deux joueurs
veulent en découdre à chaque partie oui
c'est clair non mais là en fait cramique
a eu deux fois les blancs les deux fois
il a réussi à prouver qu'il pouvait
avoir des positions gagnantes en tout
cas qu'ils étaient motivés pour les
gagner kasparov avec les blancs et moins
percutant csu ont donc pour l'instant
sur ce premier quart de match puisqu'on
a joué quatre parties on est un carton
et bien avantage net pour chronique qui
d'ailleurs se
donc cet avantage se ressent au score
deux ans et demi heure et demie pour le
challenger demain dimanche
kasparov elle et blanc que va-t-il
trouver on ne sait pas en tout cas je
vous invite à regarder
regardez cette partie en direct tout
simplement stephen tout à fait
exactement deux parties en direct entre
kasparov et kramnik la cinquième du
match aller kasparov les blancs 15h
heure anglaise dès 16 heures heure
française
à demain pour la suite